crime doing it on your bed I hope you
don't mind mind none I like the
shakiness of your move thank you I've
worked hard on this what is that cow
uh-huh it might be can we hump no we
should not
no humping the wildlife I'm sorry okay
actually there might be a dog well it's
a bit Isaac outcry it's a fat dog no
it's a cow no no let's it thought were
approaching me hey cow high jump right
okay well don't we gotta tame the beast
now we can ride into victory oh that
would be so awesome
can you punch you there something soon
will learn its place Oh like yes well I
can see your face I'm close yeah but I
don't know what to say much
beautiful yes you are you are you okay
all right let's run with our flashes and
we gotta go the techs Ami's with
flashlights yeah that's our job I'm
ready for this we got to inspect the
whole fact that there's a freaking
zombie apocalypse amongst us exactly are
you drunk